loud as hell the new today was my Creed
impression to see my life go home me
know hey what's going on YouTube nothing
I thought you here to tell you a little
story now of course all you guys out
there have homies right friends
compadres muchachos muchachas um that's
all of us on uh just because of your
friends it doesn't mean that you don't
agree on everything every now and then
you guys are gonna bump heads because
why you two different people and you got
two different thoughts now for me I
don't mind disagreeing with people just
because you don't agree with me it
doesn't mean that you're stupid it
doesn't mean I think any less of you
just means that we're different
depending on the subject though you
can't just walk around saying you want
to touch baby zombie like oh you
different that's okay no I'm called cops
I'm talking about like trivial [ __ ]
doesn't have anything to do with the
court person you are on the inside now
this friend of mine I got to a bit of an
argument and every time you argue with
your friend you already know it's about
the dumbest [ __ ] on earth so this is
what the argument was about it was about
sushi so I was making the argument that
when it comes to sushi that in most of
the time you don't need soy sauce and
wasabi so after I said that statement
this [ __ ] came back with the
response of left because you stupid his
[ __ ] oh really dude it's like that you
don't just you don't just go zero to 100
like okay let's go [ __ ]
one of my biggest pet peeves on earth is
people who don't know how to disagree
politely
you know why be my dad it means just
because somebody disagreed with you it
doesn't mean that you have to attack
them a lot of people take disagreements
as an attack on themselves so they
preemptively strike on their asses why I
can have my own opinion without being
stupid
huh-ha it's [ __ ] sushi yesterday you
use the word conversation [ __ ]
and I to say anything about that you're
dumb [ __ ] talk about we converse a [ __ ]
away at college it's so weird because at
a certain age you would think people
would be beyond this kind of [ __ ]
disagreements are supposed to happen not
everybody thinks to say not everybody is
built the same the only difference is is
that you have to be respectful of other
people's thoughts and yet I don't have
to not
because if you are not you just might
get [ __ ] up where one day for example
I disagree constantly online in front
this camera depending on who you are
because if you bought me [ __ ] I don't
want get my ass beat messes do yesterday
he just got out of prison he asked if he
could play my xbox about 60 I said you
know what it is an Xbox for 60 you don't
gret thump out his numbers and letters
education makes the man turn to think
that somebody is beneath you because you
guys don't share the same train of
thought it's incredibly infuriating and
it's always over stupid [ __ ]
that's how Wars start mother [ __ ] I
should know I'm Korean Korean people met
all the time great people are angry for
the reason is [ __ ] and you see the
Korean person pray in church salad a
minute Jesus [ __ ] ah mmm I mean this guy
still friends of course we are that's
why we say the word friends even though
we disagree we can talk about it and to
come to a mutual understanding but then
again I think it the last word in David
Malan sorry about that sometimes I just
get defensive
you don't want do I understand it's
probably payback from what I did
yesterday but what'd you do yesterday I
[ __ ] your mom [ __ ] happy birthday
David some